Julio César de ruda había sido nombrado
jefe del ejército el 30 de diciembre
pero el sábado fue despedido de su cargo
mientras continúan las consecuencias de
los disturbios del 8 de enero en
Brasilia
según el ministro de defensa su
destitución se debió a una crisis de
confianza y las autoridades necesitaban
pasar página del incidente
después de los episodios del 8 de enero
hubo una ruptura de confianza
la destitución de ruda se produce días
después de que el presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva despidiera a
miembros de su propio cuerpo y de
seguridad tras los disturbios Lula dijo
que muchos miembros del ejército los
permitieron al menos 140 militares han
sido despedidos desde que asumió el
poder el primero de enero
Muchos oficiales colaboraban con los
alborotadores estoy convencido de que la
puerta del Palacio de tan alto se abrió
para que esa gente pudiera entrar
a ruda ha sido sustituido por el
comandante militar del suroeste Tomás
Ribeiro paiva a principios de esta
semana paiva pronunció un discurso en el
que instaba los soldados aceptar los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales y dijo que el personal
debía ser apolítico los alborotadores
que interrumpieron en el congreso
brasileño el Palacio presidencial y el
tribunal supremo pretendían que los
militares intervinieran tras la votación
y anular la derrota del expresidente
Jair bolsonaro